Hi, my name is Beth and I'm a psychological wellbeing practitioner from Newcastle. I just wanted to say the biggest thank you to the contributors of the clinical psychologist collective book. I've enjoyed reading this so much and loved having an insight into the range of backgrounds and experiences people have prior to applying for the doctorate. And it's been really interesting seeing the potential barriers to the application as well and how I can try and work around this. I really started to doubt myself and whether I was good enough to apply for the clinical psychology doctorate but this has really given me the confidence boost that I needed to give it a shot so the biggest thank you ever.
嗨，我叫贝丝（Beth），是一名来自纽卡斯尔的心理健康从业人员。我只想对《临床心理学家合集》（Clinical Psychologist Collective）一书的撰稿人们表达最诚挚的感谢。我非常喜欢阅读这本书，并且很高兴能通过它深入了解人们在申请博士学位之前所拥有的各种背景和经历。看到申请过程中潜在的障碍以及我该如何尝试克服这些障碍，这也让我觉得非常有趣。我曾经真的开始怀疑自己，怀疑自己是否足够优秀去申请临床心理学博士，但这确实给了我所需要的自信，让我决定去尝试一下，所以再次致以最诚挚的谢意。
Ever wondered what it really takes to become a clinical psychologist? In this episode I share my personal journey, the highs, the heartbreak and the hope as I read aloud my chapter from the book The Clinical Psychologist Collective for the very first time. Hope you find it super useful. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I'm Dr. Marianne, a qualified clinical psychologist. But let me tell you, it's been quite the journey to get me to be the clinical psychologist that you do indeed see before you. And I know, you know, I've turned my professional hand to supporting aspiring psychologists because I loved being one, but also because I recognized just how challenging it can indeed be and is to pursue a career as a qualified and regulated
你是否想过，成为一名临床心理学家究竟需要具备什么？在本期节目中，我将首次大声朗读我在《临床心理学家合集》一书中的章节，与大家分享我的个人心路历程、高光时刻、心碎与希望。希望你会觉得超级有用。嗨，欢迎收听《有志心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist Podcast）。我是玛丽安（Dr. Marianne）博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。但老实说，为了成为你眼前这位真正的临床心理学家，我走过了一段相当漫长的旅程。我知道，正如你所了解的，我之所以将职业重心转向支持有志成为心理学家的人，是因为我曾非常热爱这个身份，但也因为我意识到，追求成为一名合格且受监管的
HCPC psychologist. So I specify there because I know that not all people listening to this podcast are actually wanting to be clinical psychologists and I know that some people are already qualified psychologists and so we've got such a broad listenership but I thought the one thing I haven't yet done is to read aloud from this book and I've never done an audiobook of the clinical psychologist collective and I know that's not always ideal but for me because it's all written by lots of different voices, for me, it would need to be that person's voice to be authentic.
HCPC心理学家，过程确实可能而且也确实非常具有挑战性。我特意这样指出来，是因为我知道并不是所有收听这个播客的人都想成为临床心理学家，我也知道有些听众本身已经是合格的心理学家了，所以我们的听众群体非常广泛。但我想，我还没做过的一件事就是大语言朗读这本书，而且我也从未制作过《临床心理学家合集》的有声书。我知道这并不总是最理想的，但对我而言，由于这本书是由许多不同的声音共同撰写的，为了保持真实性，它必须由当事人的声音来呈现。
And so, you know, because some of the stories have been written under a pseudonym, I've never done that. It's not something that I've managed to find a way to do and also, you know, remote sound quality and microphones and all of that jazz. But I wanted to let you hear my story. I wrote this story in 2021 and I don't know if I've actually read it since. So it's kind of going to be a nice trip down memory lane. And yeah, I might well talk along the way with kind of stories and anecdotes that resonate with me, or it might end up just being a read through. I don't really know. But whatever happens, I hope you find it useful. If you are watching on YouTube, please do subscribe, please do drop
而且，你知道的，由于有些故事是用笔名写的，我从来没有做过这件事。这不是我能找到方法去做的事情，而且还有远程音质、麦克风以及诸如此类的一大堆问题。但我希望你能听到我的故事。这个故事是我在2021年写的，我不知道自从那以后我有没有真正读过它。所以这感觉就像是一次美好的怀旧之旅。而且，是的，在讲述的过程中，我可能会顺便聊一些与我共鸣的故事和趣闻，或者也可能最终只是通读一遍。我其实并不确定。但无论如何，希望你觉得它对你有用。如果你正在YouTube上观看，请务必订阅，请务必留下
a comment. If you're listening on Spotify, you can drop Q&As there. You can also rate the show. If you're listening on Apple Podcasts, you, you are very special because you get to rate and review the show. So please do because it helps demonstrate that this podcast is really worth listening to and gets it pushed out to a wider audience. And wherever you're listening or watching, the kindest thing you can do for any podcaster or content creator is to subscribe or follow their show. So with no further ado, let's pick up my copy of The Clinical Psychologist Collective, which usually lives behind me on this desk, but today is in my hands. And before we get into my story, I'd like to read you the very powerful dedication.
评论。如果你正在Spotify上收听，你可以在那里留下问答。你也可以为节目评分。如果你正在收听Apple Podcasts，那么你，你非常特别，因为你可以对节目进行评分和评价。所以请务必这样做，因为这有助于证明这个播客确实值得一听，并能将其推向更广泛的受众。无论你在哪里收听或观看，你能为一个播客创作者或内容创作者做的最贴心的事，就是订阅或关注他们的节目。废话不多说，让我们拿起我的那本《临床心理学家合集》。它通常放在我身后这张书桌的后面，但今天它就在我的手上。在进入我的故事之前，我想为你朗读这段非常有力量的卷首献词。
This book is dedicated to the memory of Dr Stephen Wright, a wonderful clinical psychologist who I'm sad I never got to meet. We often spoke via Facebook and his wit and professionalism were so admired by me and others within our network. He was passionate about supporting children, young people and their families with their mental health needs. At the time of his unexpected death from vaccine-induced thrombosis with thrombocytopenia, brackets V-I-T-T, in January 2021, he was days away from starting a new role with Great Ormond Street Hospital and he also worked in private practice in his business, Oakes Child and Adolescent Psychology.
本书谨献给斯蒂芬·赖特（Dr Stephen Wright）博士的在天之灵。他是一位杰出的临床心理学家，遗憾的是我从未能与他相见。我们经常通过Facebook交流，他的机智和专业精神让我以及我们网络中的其他人深表钦佩。他热衷于支持儿童、青少年及其家人的心理健康需求。2021年1月，他因疫苗诱导性免疫血栓性血小板减少症（简称V-I-T-T）不幸离世，就在离世前几天，他刚刚准备在大奥蒙德街医院（Great Ormond Street Hospital）开始新的工作，同时他还在自己的企业“奥克斯儿童与青少年心理学”（Oaks Child and Adolescent Psychology）开展私人执业。
He is survived by his wife Charlotte and their two young sons, Isaac and Elijah. Charlotte and Stephen met a few years before he started training, and they had their first child in 2013, shortly before starting on the course in 2014. He qualified in 2017. He is also much missed by his parents Anne and Richard and his sister Sarah, brother-in-law Sam and his nephew
他的离去留下了他的妻子夏洛特（Charlotte）和他们两个年幼的儿子伊萨克（Isaac）和以利亚（Elijah）。夏洛特和斯蒂芬在他开始接受培训几年前就相识了，他们在2013年有了第一个孩子，不久后，即2014年，他开始攻读课程。他在2017年获得了资格。他的父母安（Anne）和理查德（Richard）、姐姐莎拉（Sarah）、姐夫萨姆（Sam）以及他的侄子
Finlay. Dr. Stephen Christopher Wright 1988 to 2021. Chapter 26, Marianne's story, owning our story. I honestly think I have the best job in the world, and sometimes I have to pinch myself to reflect upon the fact that I get paid for doing stuff, which makes me really happy. When I was studying my undergrad course at Glamorgan University,
芬利（Finlay）也对深感痛惜。斯蒂芬·克里斯托弗·赖特博士，1988年至2021年。第二十六章，玛丽安的故事，掌控我们自己的故事。我真心觉得我拥有世界上最好的工作，有时我不得不掐自己一下，来回想这样一个事实：我因为做那些让我感到非常快乐的事情而获得报酬。当我还在格拉摩根大学（Glamorgan University）攻读本科课程时，
I actually found the module on clinical psychology pretty boring. It seemed to only be about data and neuropsych testing, and with only theory and textbooks to look at, it all felt a bit dry. I love learning from experience and learning about people and hearing them speak. For me, it just didn't appeal. I don't even really recall having heard of the job title clinical psychologist until the week before my undergrad finals. We all traipsed into the lecture theatre for a chat on different career options post-graduation. One of the lecturers mentioned what a clinical psychologist did and how it was super hard to get into training.
我其实觉得临床心理学这门课相当无聊。它似乎只关乎数据和神经心理学测试，而且只有理论和教科书可看，这一切让人感觉有点枯燥。我喜欢从经验中学习，了解人并听他们说话。对我来说，这实在没什么吸引力。我甚至不记得在本科期末考试前一周之前，自己曾听说过“临床心理学家”这个职位名称。我们都晃晃悠悠地走进阶梯教室，听一场关于毕业后不同职业选择的讲座。其中一位讲师提到了临床心理学家是做什么的，以及进入这个培训项目有多么超级困难。
She said we probably shouldn't bother and should do something else instead. Well, that was enough for me. From that point forwards, that's the career I wanted. The thing is, I know that I'm not alone in that either. I'm in a psychologist Facebook group of over 3,000 people and in a recent post surveying why people got into the profession, a staggeringly high number of us said that part of our motivation for becoming a clinical psychologist was because we had been told just how difficult it was. Seriously, what does that say about our dogged determination, our desire to prove ourselves,
她说我们大概不用费心思了，还是去做点别的吧。好吧，这就够了。从那一刻起，这就是我想要的职业。问题是，我也知道自己并不孤单。我在一个拥有3000多名成员的心理学家Facebook群组里，在最近一个调查人们为何进入这个行业的帖子中，极高比例的人表示，他们成为临床心理学家的部分动机，正是因为别人告诉他们这有多么困难。说真的，这说明了我们怎样的顽强意志、想要证明自己的渴望，
maybe even our masochism, perfectionism and ego? Well, there's a doctoral thesis topic for you if you ever needed one. I think it's interesting that at the time I see there were 3,000 people in that Facebook group, and I've just had a little look now and it's six and a half thousand and it's a group for psychologists in private practice and it seems that since 2021, there's been quite the explosion of people
甚至我们的受虐倾向、完美主义和自我意识？好吧，如果你需要的话，这倒是个不错的博士论文选题。我觉得很有意思的是，当时我看到那个Facebook群组里有3000人，而我刚才稍微看了一下，现在已经有六千五百人了。这是一个面向私人执业心理学家的群组，似乎自2021年以来，
either starting their private practice or suddenly surveying their options. Let's get back to 2021, Marianne. Speaking of ego, I gained my first AP post, that means assistant psychologist by the way, at St. Andrews Healthcare, and they had the coolest name badges. They were gold enamel, and they said my name and job title,
无论是开始私人执业还是突然探索各种选择的人数，都有了相当大的爆发式增长。让我们回到2021年的玛丽安。说到自我意识，我获得了第一份AP工作——顺便说一下，这意味着助理心理学家——是在圣安德鲁斯医疗保健公司（St. Andrews Healthcare），他们拥有最酷的工作证。它们是金色珐琅材质的，上面写着我的名字和职位，
Marianne Duran, assistant psychologist. Honestly, wearing that little beauty for the first time and checking myself out in the mirrored walls on one of the wards in the cool new Assistant Psychologist clothes I had bought to compliment the gold badge remains one of my proudest psychology moments to date. I wish I still had that badge.
玛丽安·杜兰（Marianne Duran），助理心理学家。老实说，第一次戴着那个小可爱，在其中一个病房的镜面墙前打量自己，身上穿着为了搭配这个金色徽章而特意买的帅气的新助理心理学家服装，至今仍是我心理学之路上最让我感到自豪的时刻之一。我真希望我到现在还留着那个徽章。
I wonder where it is. I think they made me give it back when I left. Maybe I should make myself a gold badge now. Probably wouldn't look nearly as snazzy teamed with my working from home pyjama bottoms though. The thing is, I think I'm probably much less of an arse now I'm qualified than I was when I was an assistant. One of my pet hates is when people refer to themselves as psychologists when actually they've only done an undergrad. I wish psychologist was a proper protected title so that everyone knew they were in safe hands.
我不知道它在哪里。我想我离开时他们让我把它还回去了。也许我现在应该自己做一个金色徽章。不过，如果把它跟我居家办公穿的睡裤搭配在一起，大概看起来就没那么时髦了。问题是，我觉得我现在拿到资质后，可能比当助理时要少了很多傲慢。我最讨厌的事情之一，就是有些人明明只读了个本科，却管自己叫心理学家。我真希望心理学家是一个受到法律严格保护的称号，这样每个人都知道他们是在安全的手中。
Confession time. I wonder whether it irks me so much because actually that used to be me. I loved chatting to people and telling them that I was a psychologist when actually I was an assistant psychologist. These days I'm proud to be a psychologist but I don't tend to tell anyone who will listen that I am one. I think there's something to be said about the imposter curve. The less we know the more naive we are to this. And as we get more experienced, we become more aware of everything we don't know, and we are more likely to stay within our limits.
坦白时间。我在想，这事儿之所以这么让我恼火，是不是因为过去我其实也就是这样。我喜欢跟人聊天，告诉他们我是一名心理学家，而实际上我只是一名助理心理学家。如今，我为自己成为一名心理学家而感到自豪，但我不再逢人便说我是个心理学家了。关于“冒名顶替曲线”，有些道理值得一说。我们知道得越少，对此就越天真。而随着我们经验越来越丰富，我们会对所有自己不知道的事情有了更多意识，我们也更有可能坚守在自己的能力范围内。
So, in 2007, whilst I was completing my form, it's fair to say that I wasn't having the best time of life. My friend Kara refers to this stage in life as that where I mainly ate carrots and hummus. At the start of August I decided to separate from a long-term partner which had not been easy. A few weeks later whilst on my way to my first ever boot camp class, and then there's a little footnote, I never did make it to the bootcamp class and never been to one since either. It wasn't meant to be, I guess. Although, as an aside, I have now been
所以，在2007年，当我正在填写申请表的时候，坦白说，我当时的生活过得并不是最好。我的朋友卡拉（Kara）把人生中的这个阶段称为“我主要靠胡萝卜和鹰嘴豆泥度日”的时期。八月初，我决定和一个长期伴侣分开，这并不容易。几个星期后，在我前往人生第一节训练营（boot camp）课程的路上——这里还有一个小脚注：我其实根本没去成那节训练营，后来也再没去过。我想，这就是命中注定吧。不过，顺便说一句，我现在已经去过
to several bootcamp-style classes. So this is the growth that can occur for you in four years. So let's go back to before the little footnote so that this makes sense. A few weeks later, whilst on my way to my first ever boot camp class, a chap in a jugular crashed into me in my beautiful Yaris. My car was written off. I got whiplash in my neck and back and almost immediately after I started studying for my masters with Newman University College. They're now just called Newman University. This was all
好几次训练营风格的课程了。所以这就是四年时间里你可以获得的成长。让我们回到那个小脚注之前，这样上下文才讲得通。几星期后，在我前往人生第一节训练营课程的路上，一个开着捷古斯（jugular）的家伙撞上了我漂亮的雅力士（Yaris）轿车。我的车报废了。我的颈部和背部得了挥鞭样损伤，几乎紧接着，我就开始在纽曼大学学院（Newman University College）攻读我的硕士学位。他们现在简称为纽曼大学。这一切
whilst working full-time and being in pain whilst striving for my first ever NHS assistant post. I was applying for jobs all over the country. I recall at one stage crying on the stairs at home the day before an assistant interview in Nottingham. I was in pain. It was in the days before I owned a sat nav and I wasn't even sure it was a job I wanted anyway, but I really wanted it for the form. My mum, clearly a bit shocked, actually did pull it out the bag and say, if it's too much, then just cancel the interview. Don't go. So that's what I did and instead spent my day off doing a bit of R&R, and likely for
都是在全职工作、忍受病痛折磨的同时进行的，为的是争取我第一份NHS助理的工作。我当时在全国各地到处申请工作。我记得有一次，在诺丁汉的一场助理面试前一天，我在家里的楼梯上哭了。我很痛苦。那是还没有车载导航（sat nav）的年代，我甚至不确定这到底是不是一份我想要的工作，但我真的很想通过申请表。我妈妈显然有点震惊，居然真的给出了一记神助攻，说：“如果压力太大了，那就取消面试吧。别去了。”所以我就这么做了，转而把假期花在放松和休养上，
me at the time probably listening to a bit of R&B. So other than listening to Chris Brown and Neo, it's fair to say that it wasn't an easy time in my life, but it did give me a lot of time to focus on my form. I recall laying half slouched on my parents' sofa with my laptop propped on my knee and stomach for what seemed like any spare minute of the day in September, October and November. And then there's another little footnote. Genuinely, this is the way I'm sitting right now except now I own the sofa. I was a woman on a mission with my form. This was my third time applying but the first I thought I might
对我当时来说，可能还听了一点R&B。所以除了听克里斯·布朗（Chris Brown）和内约（Ne-Yo）的歌之外，坦白讲，那并不是我生活中轻松的一段时期，但它确实给了我很多时间来专注于我的申请表。我记得在9月、10月和11月的那些日子里，似乎只要有任何空闲时间，我都半躺在父母的沙发上，把笔记本电脑架在膝盖和肚子上。然后这里还有另一个小脚注：说实话，我现在的坐姿就是这样，只不过现在这张沙发归我了。对于这份申请表，我简直是一个带着使命的女人。这是我第三次申请，但我第一次觉得
stand a chance. It was the year that I just did me. I didn't show it to anyone. I wanted to make sure it sounded like me. So many, many times over, for each revision I made, I read the form aloud to myself. I'm sure I was quite annoying to my mum, who was watching Coronation Street or whatever on the other sofa. And another footnote, editorial comment. I'm shocked and even a little bit disappointed that I've gotten this far into your story and you've reigned yourself in with the swearing. None of your famous one-liners that I've grown to love either. Readers will just have to listen to your lives to experience the best of Marianne. Never a dull moment with you. Being your editorial assistant makes me so happy. Interestingly, I never swear on the podcast because then I'd have to mark myself as X-rated,
自己或许有一点胜算。那是我只做自己的一年。我没有把表拿给任何人看。我想确保它听起来就是我自己的声音。无数次，在我做出的每一次修改中，我都大声把申请表读给自己听。我确信我一定挺招我妈烦的，当时她正在另一张沙发上看《加冕街》（Coronation Street）之类的节目。还有另一个脚注，编辑评论：我很震惊，甚至还有点失望，你的故事都进行到这里了，你居然还能管住自己不爆粗口。也没有那些我日渐喜爱、你标志性的金句。读者们只能去听你的直播才能体验到最真实的玛丽安了。跟你在一起从来没有沉闷的时刻。做你的助理编辑让我感到无比快乐。有趣的是，我在播客里从来不爆粗口，因为那样的话我就得把节目标记为限制级，
and that limits my reach. So you guys might know that I actually do enjoy a little bit of a swear word every now and then. My rule was that if I felt embarrassed saying it aloud or if it wasn't the way I'd actually speak in person, I did rein in my urge to swear. Then it wasn't going in. And then another footnote, for projects like this one I still write in that style now too. If it's the way I'd speak, I'll start sentences with and and all sorts and I'm sure I'm a nightmare for my editorial assistant Chrissie. As a result, when it was eventually time to stand in the post office queue and dispatch it, I was absolutely thrilled with my form.
这会限制我的受众触达。所以你们可能会知道，其实我偶尔还是挺喜欢爆点粗口的。我的原则是，如果我大声说出来会感到尴尬，或者这不是我私下实际说话的方式，我就会克制自己爆粗口的冲动。那样的话，它就不会出现在表里。然后又是一个脚注：对于像这样的项目，我现在依然以那种风格写作。如果那是我说话的方式，我就会用“和”之类的词开头，而且我确信我对我的助理编辑克里西（Chrissie）来说简直是个噩梦。因此，当终于到了站在邮局队伍里把它寄出的那一刻，我对自己的申请表感到极其满意。
Whilst far from ideal, this time in my life did turn out to be a useful reflecting point though. Seven months later, after the the accident a fair bit of Osteopathy and Pilates and lots of partying with my assistant and non psychology friends later my back and my heart were in much finer shape. It was in my personal suitability interview for the course that I was asked to reflect on a difficult time in my life and that was it. Don't be afraid to be vulnerable. They need to see and to know that you can be human and that if required you are able to use appropriate help seeking too. When we deny the story it defines us. When we own the story we can write
虽然远非理想，但我生活中的这段时期，后来确实成为了一个很有用的反思点。事故发生七个月后，经过相当多的整骨疗法（Osteopathy）和普拉提（Pilates），以及跟我的助理和非心理学朋友们进行的大量派对之后，我的背部和我的心脏都恢复到了好得多的状态。正是在课程的个人契合度面试中，我被要求反思我人生中一段艰难的时期，就是这样。不要害怕展露脆弱。他们需要看到并了解你是有血有肉的人，并且在需要时，你也能够寻求适当的帮助。当我们否认故事时，故事便定义了我们；当我们掌控故事时，我们就能写下
a brave new ending. That's a little quote by Brené Brown. I was in the fortunate position that I was offered two places for doctoral training. I do often think now that if I had picked the other course that my life would be entirely different. Genuinely, some of my consideration for which course to choose at the time weighed up the fact that at interview one course had profited a selection of my favourite herbal teas for my delectation whilst the other had made me cry. Which did I pick? Simple. I'm a martyr. I picked the crying. Just kidding. I of course picked the course which felt like it was a bit of me from the moment I arrived. But had the course where I'd sobbed in my car as soon as I got back to the end of the day been my only offer then I would have accepted it and likely been on Cloud9 to do
勇敢的全新结局。这是布琳·布朗（Brené Brown）的一句名言。我很幸运地获得了两个博士培训项目的录用名额。我现在经常想，如果当时我选了另一个课程，我的人生将完全不同。说实话，当时我在权衡选择哪个课程时，其中一个考量因素是：在面试时，其中一个课程为我准备了我最喜欢的花草茶供我享用，而另一个课程却把我弄哭了。我选了哪个？很简单。我是个烈士。我选了那个把人弄哭的。开玩笑的。我当然是选了那个从我到达那一刻起就让我觉得“这就是我想要的”课程。但如果那个让我一到傍晚回到车里就放声大哭的项目是我唯一的offer，那么我也会接受它，并且大概会高兴得飘飘欲仙。
so. The year I successfully applied was the year where the Bristol course was cancelled. I had done my Bristol selection test from home, been invited to do another test in Bristol and then been invited to interview. Then, due to a misunderstanding with the way a new university were planning on running the course as solely academic with no placements, without warning, the plug was pulled.
我成功申请的那一年，正是布里斯托课程被取消的那一年。我在家里做完了布里斯托的选拔测试，被邀请去布里斯托参加另一场测试，然后又被邀请去面试。接着，由于对一所新大学计划如何运行该课程产生误解——他们计划将其设为纯学术课程、不设实习安排——在毫无预警的情况下，这个项目被叫停了。
This was because a taught-only method was not gonna churn out the type of clinical psychologists we needed to be, ones who were effective and practiced at being with clinical patients and clients. In turn, hearts were broken for people whose only interviews that year were on the Bristol course. I really fancied Bristol and had the course gone ahead and I'd been successful at interview,
这是因为纯授课的方法无法培养出我们所需要的那类临床心理学家，即那些高效且在与临床患者和客户相处方面经验丰富的人。反过来，对于那些那一年唯一的面试机会就在布里斯托课程的人来说，他们的心碎了。我其实非常中意布里斯托，如果那个课程顺利进行下去而且我在面试中成功的话，
I might well have ended up there as it was close to a number of my close friends from my undergrad days which would have just been lovely. As it turned out my herbal tea course was Coventry Amaric and I'm delighted to say that I absolutely loved training. I felt like I went into it with my eyes open. Sometimes it would be hard, I would need to juggle my social life, academic life and placement commitments and then at times it would be hard, I would need to juggle my social life, academic life and placement commitments, and then at times it would be pressured and stressful. Sometimes it was, but largely I found that by using my study days pretty much exclusively for study, that until my thesis
我最终很可能会去那里，因为那离我在本科时期的许多挚友很近，那将是一件非常美好的事。事实证明，我的花草茶课程是考文垂阿马里克（Coventry Amaric），我非常高兴地宣布，我绝对热爱这段培训经历。我觉得自己是睁大双眼走进去的。有时它会很艰难，我需要兼顾我的社交生活、学术生活和实习安排；有时又会压力重重、令人焦虑。有时确实如此，但我大体上发现，只要几乎把学习日专门用来学习，那么直到我的论文
rolled around, hand on heart, I didn't do any work in the evenings or weekends. I think that what was useful for me personally and professionally was that our course gave out pass or fail marks for academic work. There were no percentages, there was no direct way to compare scores across the cohort and so, as a result of this, my perfectionistic tendencies could be chucked out the window entirely. I aimed to pass and for all but one assignment in the three years, this is exactly what I did and that was good enough for me. It did get a bit grim in my viva, but that all turned out marvellously in the end too and happily I still managed to graduate with
交稿前夕，我摸着良心说，我从来没有在晚上或周末工作过。我认为对我和我的职业生涯都很有用的一点是，我们的课程对学术作业给出的是通过或不通过（pass or fail）的成绩。没有百分制分数，没有直接在整个cohort（同年级学员）中横向比较分数的方式，因此，由于这一点，我内心的完美主义倾向可以被彻底抛到九霄云外。我的目标是通过，在三年内除了其中一个作业之外，这正是我所做到的，对我来说这就足够了。我的毕业答辩（viva）过程确实变得有点严峻，但最终结果也堪称完美，而且令人高兴的是，我依然成功地与
my cohort. Standing in Coventry Cathedral with my coat of many colours and my funny squashy hat was genuinely a wonderfully proud moment, almost as good as that gold badge. I love reflecting that my dad was there watching because fit and healthy at the time, sadly just over five years later he died. I had been in the very fortunate position that he and my mum had always supported my career. Although it's fair to say, I don't think they understood what it was. My mum really wanted me and my brother to go to higher education so that we would have different chances in life. My dad was a boiler man and I could not have been more proud of him but two days before he died, I was holding his hand and he said to me, I wish I'd tried harder at school. The idea that my kind, sweet, palliatively unwell,
我的同学们一起毕业了。站在考文垂大教堂里，穿着我那件百家衣般的外套和滑稽的软帽，真的是一个无比自豪的时刻，几乎和那个金色徽章一样棒。我很喜欢回想我的爸爸当时也在那里看着，因为当时他身体硬朗健康，遗憾的是仅仅五年多后他就去世了。我很幸运，他和妈妈一直都支持我的职业生涯。尽管平心而论，我觉得他们并不懂那是做什么的。我妈妈真的很希望我和我弟弟接受高等教育，这样我们在生活中能有不同的机会。我爸爸是一名锅炉工，我对他感到无比自豪，但在他去世前两天，我握着他的手，他对我说：“我真希望当初在学校时能再努力一点。”这种想法——我善良、温柔、处于临终阶段的
71 year old father was having regrets of this kind was so sad making for me. But on the other hand it's probably a life well lived if that's as big as your end of life regrets get. And then as a little footnote, there's more of this story in the grief collective – stories of life, loss, learning to heal. So do check this out if you'd like more. My top tips. And there's another little footnote. Dr Robbo, if you ever read this, I can imagine
71岁父亲竟然会有这种遗憾——让我感到非常难过。但另一方面，如果这就是你临终前最大的遗憾，那大概也算是不枉此生了。接着是一个小脚注：在《悲伤合集——生命、失去与学习治愈的故事》（The Grief Collective – stories of life, loss, learning to heal）中还有更多这样的故事。如果你想要了解更多，请务必去看看。我的实用小贴士。这里还有另一个小脚注：罗博博士（Dr Robbo），如果你读到这里，我能想象
you finding this VIZ inspired title very amusing. Have loads of fun. Honestly. Please do. It helps us to weather the storm. I have just the fondest memories of my assistant years. Many of my assistant friends are still some of my closest friends now. And two, even ended up in my cohort too. Masters Study In 2007, I started a distance learning part-time masters course with Newman whilst I was also working full-time as an assistant across three busy inpatient wards for St Andrews. If it's a possibility for
你会觉得这个受《VIZ》杂志启发的标题非常有趣。尽情享受乐趣吧。说真的。一定要这样。这有助于我们度过难关。我对助理岁月的记忆简直美好至极。我的许多助理朋友现在依然是我最亲密的朋友。而且其中两人，最终还成了我同届的同学。硕士学习：2007年，我在圣安德鲁斯三家繁忙的住院病房全职担任助理的同时，开始通过纽曼大学修读远程兼职硕士课程。如果这对你来说
you I would say that distance learning part-time masters are an excellent way to build academic experience because it allows you to work full-time at the same time. If you have kids it would be more of a struggle too of course. Although as I am learning with my book writing projects when required I can work when my kids are sleeping. At the time when doing my masters we had to travel in for exams and one Saturday of teaching per module but I think in-person teaching was later reduced to be more inclusive for distance students. Due to the appeal of the flexible nature of the course there was a lady on my cohort from Ireland so do check it out if you'd like to add some more strings to your academic bow. I found it invaluable because it taught us how to plan research and how
是可能的，我想说，远程兼职硕士是建立学术经验的绝佳途径，因为它允许你同时进行全职工作。当然，如果你有孩子，这会是一场更艰难的挣扎。不过，正如我在写作项目中所学到的那样，必要时我可以在孩子们睡觉时工作。当时读硕士时，我们必须亲自去参加考试，并且每个模块要参加一个周六的面授课，但我想后来面授教学减少了，以便对远程学生更具包容性。由于该课程灵活性的吸引力，我同届里还有一位来自爱尔兰的女士，所以如果你想为你的学术弓箭增添更多羽翼，不妨去了解一下。我发现它无价宝贵，因为它教会了我们如何规划研究，
to pick it apart and discuss it analytically. These were strategies I then used for assistant training and qualified interviews too. This might be a really great aside to tell you about the aspiring psychologist membership as well because research is a real strength of what we do and a lot of the skills that you can get from being on a masters you can also get for a fraction of the cost on the Aspiring Psychologist membership. So please do head along to my website www.aspiring-psychologist.co.uk where you can learn more about the Aspiring Psychologist membership which you can join from just £30 a month with no minimum term.
以及如何剖析和进行分析性讨论。这些是我后来用于助理培训和合格面试的策略。这可能是一个非常棒的题外话，可以顺便向你介绍“有志心理学家会员”（Aspiring Psychologist membership），因为研究是我们工作的真正优势所在，你在硕士期间可以获得的许多技能，也可以在“有志心理学家会员”中以极小的一部分成本获得。所以请务必前往我的网站 www.aspiring-psychologist.co.uk，在那里你可以了解更多关于“有志心理学家会员”的信息，只需每月30英镑起即可加入，且无最低合约期限制。
People often ask when is the right time for me to join? I would say it's probably post undergraduate degree when you're perhaps looking for your first assistant psychologist post or PWP post or support worker role and even if you're already working in those roles as well. If you're starting to apply for doctoral training courses, maybe even if you have interviews. Basically, I'd say it's anytime post-grad because we can absolutely meet you where you are and people will get different things from the content based on what stage of their learning journey they are at. So yeah if you think it might be for you why not check out the website. If you've got any questions reach out to me as well. Okay back to the story.
人们经常问：什么时候是我加入的正确时机？我会说，大概是在本科毕业后，当你可能正在寻找你的第一个助理心理学家职位、PWP职位或支持工作者角色时，甚至当你已经在这些岗位上工作时。如果你开始申请博士培训课程，甚至如果你已经拿到了面试机会。基本上，我会说毕业后的任何时候都可以，因为我们完全可以根据你目前所处的阶段来提供帮助，大家会根据自己所处的学习旅程阶段从内容中获得不同的东西。所以，是的，如果你觉得这可能适合你，为什么不去看一下网站呢？如果你有任何问题，也可以联系我。好了，回到故事。
CV gap plugging the creative way number one. I was desperate to get my foot in the door and get my first AP post. I took 10 days of annual leave from my social rehabilitation work with physically disabled adults and sorted out an honorary post one day a week spread over four months and it was enough. It gave me a clean psych as a reference and opened the door for the first time to being behind the clinic room door and discussing psychological terms, concepts, and theories with a real life clinical psychologist.
创意填补简历空白法第一招。我当时迫切想要迈进这个行业并获得我的第一份AP工作。我从为身体残疾成年人提供社会康复的工作中请了10天年假，安排了一份每周一天、历时四个月的荣誉职位（honorary post），这就足够了。它为我提供了一个纯粹的心理学参考人，并第一次打开了走进诊室大门、与现实生活中的临床心理学家讨论心理学术语、概念和理论的大门。
I was hooked. Whilst it meant less annual leave that year, I think this was, for me at least, an excellent way of gaining experience without necessarily having to lose any money. So do bear that in mind. The unit loved having me too because assistant psychologists are such a fantastic resource and they'd never had one before. I seem to recall after I left
我彻底迷上了。虽然这意味着那一年的年假变少了，但至少对我而言，这是在不一定非要损失金钱的情况下获得经验的绝佳方式。所以请把这一点记在心里。单位也非常喜欢我的加入，因为助理心理学家是一种非常宝贵的资源，而且他们以前从未有过助理。我记得在我离开后，
they did go on to then employ one too. So it paves the way and shows just how useful and essential assistants are. I finished this post in the summer, and by October, I was starting my first paid assistant post. There is another video you can watch or listen to about the ethics of honorary assistant psychologist posts, so please do check that out if you get a chance. CV gap plugging, the creative way number two. By the time I was six years post undergrad,
他们确实接着也雇佣了一位助理。所以这铺平了道路，也展现了助理是多么有用和不可或缺。我在夏天结束了这份工作，到了10月份，我便开始了自己的第一份带薪助理工作。还有另一个视频你可以观看或收听，探讨荣誉助理心理学家职位的道德问题，如果你有机会的话请务必去看看。创意填补简历空白法第二招。当我本科毕业六年时，
I had experience working with physically disabled adults, working age adults, older adults and forensic clients. I'd also had a wicked time traveling around the world for eight months and temping in offices and doing home caring to fund it. Another little footnote, no time or space to discuss home caring here, but I loved that job. Such a privilege and actually laughed a lot with my clients, but also taught me a lot about dignity, respect and trust. Also gave me lots of opportunities to wonder at 3am in the morning whether I'd remembered to lock my clients door. I had zero experience with children and young people. I reached out to a local Brownie group and there followed two years
我拥有了与身体残疾成人、适龄成人、老年人以及法医客户合作的经验。我还经历了一段长达八个月的环球旅行的疯狂时光，期间靠做办公室临时工和居家护理来资助它。另一个小脚注：这里没有时间和空间讨论居家护理，但我太喜欢那份工作了。那是一种特权，实际上我和客户们一起笑过很多次，它也教给了我很多关于尊严、尊重和信任的知识。同时也给了我很多机会，让我在凌晨三点纳闷自己到底有没有锁好客户的门。我对儿童和青少年毫无经验。我联系了一个当地的布朗尼女童军团（Brownie group），接着便迎来了两年
of the most incredible learning and fun experiences as honorary Wise Owl. It was so helpful to learn about the normal scope of children rather than just the clinical aspect I would later see. I could also totally fit one evening a week into my schedule too. Being able to speak about these children in my secure training unit interview for young people totally bagged me my first NHS assistant post too. So it worked. CV Gap Plugging The Creative Way 3 Reach out to your local NHS trust and ask if there are any research meetings or groups
最不可思议的学习和趣味经历，担任名誉“聪明的猫头鹰”（Wise Owl）。了解儿童的正常发展范围，而不是我后来会看到的纯临床方面，这真的非常有帮助。我也完全能把每周一个晚上的时间塞进我的日程表里。能够在针对年轻人的安全培训单位面试中谈论这些孩子，彻底帮我拿下了我的第一份NHS助理工作。所以这招管用。创意填补简历空白法第三招：联系你当地的NHS信托基金会，询问是否有任何研究会议或小组，
or any key researchers you can be put in touch with. I learned a lot of useful stuff for my thesis by going along to research meetings whilst I was training. If you don't yet have research experience, you could also find some honorary stuff which will look great on your CV too. When I was an assistant, in exchange for being able to put honorary research assistant on my form, I helped to trainee out with some of her bits and pieces for data collection too. Create and count your publications. When I was striving for training, no one in my department was free to present their research at an upcoming international conference in Nottingham. So I volunteered and they were delighted I had. And so I did it. I put it on my form as it
或者是否有你可以被引荐的任何关键研究人员。我在培训期间通过参加研究会议，学到了很多对我的论文非常有用的东西。如果你还没有研究经验，你也可以找一些荣誉性质的工作，这在你的简历上也会显得很棒。当我当助理时，作为能够在申请表上写上“名誉研究助理”的回报，我也帮一位培训生处理了她的一些数据收集工作。创作并计算你的出版物。当我努力争取培训时，我部门里没有人有空在即将于诺丁汉举办的国际会议上展示他们的研究。所以我自愿去了，他们对此感到非常高兴。于是我照做了。我把它写进了申请表里，因为这
counts as a publication. I also wrote a vaguely amusing post-conference report and submitted it to a journal. It was accepted and published and you've guessed it, it counted as a publication. I also offered to write up the research for a journal because the qualified staff were struggling to find the time and then ended up as third author for the project. Think about ways you can gain publication experience which might involve thinking outside the box and asking for opportunities. Can you get involved with a book or research? You do you. Be you. You're great. Reflect and make sure the form sounds like you and shows your unique skills, talents and interests.
算作一篇出版物。我还写了一份略带趣味性的会后报告，并将其提交给了一家期刊。它被接收并发表了——你猜对了，它算作一篇出版物。我还主动提出为一家期刊撰写研究报告，因为有资质的员工正艰难地抽不出时间，结果我成了该项目的第三作者。思考你可以通过哪些方式获得出版物经验，这可能需要你跳出框框思考并主动争取机会。你能参与一本书或研究吗？做你自己。成为你自己。你很棒。反思并确保申请表听起来像你自己的声音，并展现出你独特的技能、才华和兴趣。
Consider using section subheadings so that your form makes sense and flows well. In forms I have reviewed, I often find that answering questions in massive full sentences is a waste of space. Be concise but easy to understand. Don't use fancy words which mean nothing. Don't leave the relevant experience section blank. Fill the space on your form but make sure it's easy to read. I also prefer to read in a present tense. You've not lost the skills just because you're no longer doing that job.
考虑使用小标题，这样你的申请表才能通顺易懂、逻辑清晰。在我审阅过的申请表中，我经常发现用大段完整的句子回答问题完全是在浪费篇幅。要简明扼要但易于理解。不要使用毫无意义的华丽辞藻。不要把相关经验部分留空。填满申请表上的空间，但要确保易于阅读。我也更倾向于用现在时来阅读。你并没有因为不再做那份工作而失去这些技能。
These are some of the observations I made in a form I reviewed last year. This is page 6 in the application and I currently feel I know nothing about you or what interests you or what makes you unique. I feel this whole section falls a bit flat. Try not to just tick boxes for the sake of it. Be interested and interesting. It's often a good idea to get someone qualified to review your form. It's much better to get this feedback from someone before you submit your form. It's much better to get this feedback from someone before you submit your form, rather than it be thought by someone screening your form at your dream course. No one is coming to save you. Reach out to people, create opportunities for
这些是我去年审阅的一份申请表中得出的一些观察结果。这是申请表的第6页，我目前觉得我对你一无所知，不知道你对什么感兴趣，也不知道是什么让你变得独一无二。我觉得整个部分显得有点平淡无力。尽量不要为了打勾而打勾。要做到对人感兴趣且自身有趣。找一个有资质的人来审阅你的申请表通常是个好主意。最好在提交申请表之前就从别人那里获得这种反馈。最好在提交申请表之前就从别人那里获得这种反馈，而不是让你的梦想课程的申请表筛选人员去替你想。没有人会来拯救你。主动联系他人，为
yourself, chance it. If you don't ask, you're much less likely to get. You literally have nothing to lose and potentially everything to gain. Practice interviews. I absolutely cringed at the time and definitely didn't want to do it but in 2008 my NHS supervisor Charlotte did a mock interview for me ahead of my two clinical interviews. It was fantastically helpful and got my rabbit in the headlights moments out of the way in a supportive and risk-free situation. This is something I've done for a number of assistants too and they all universally cringe but all say it was helpful in retrospect. Speaking of cringing, Charlotte was also present for my first ever therapy session with a young person. Honestly, it was dreadful, so awkward. It was in a forensic unit and the young person was far cooler than me.
自己创造机会，去搏一把。如果你不问，你得到的机会就会小得多。你literally（简直）没有什么可失去的，却有可能赢得一切。练习面试。我当时感到极其尴尬，而且绝对不想这样做，但在2008年，我的NHS主管夏洛特（Charlotte）在我进行两次临床面试前为我做了一场模拟面试。这真的超级有帮助，在一个支持性且无风险的环境中，把我那种“惊恐得像看到车灯的兔子”的时刻给提前消解了。这也是我为许多助理做过的事情，他们虽然一开始都普遍感到尴尬，但事后都说这很有帮助。说到尴尬，夏洛特当时也在场，那是我的第一场与年轻人的心理治疗。老实说，太糟糕了，极其尴尬。那是在一个法医单元，那个年轻人比我酷得多。
To both Charlotte and the young person, thanks and sorry. I'm now much better at therapy but couldn't have got there without either of you. Lastly, follow your dreams. The other day my eight-year-old son asked me a question. Mummy, when you were younger, what did you want to be when you grew up? A doctor and a journalist, I replied. Oh, but that's not your job now. You don't read the news. Well, no, baby, but I was on it once.
向夏洛特和那个年轻人致谢并表示歉意。我现在擅长做心理治疗多了，但没有你们俩的帮助，我是走不到这一步的。最后，追随你的梦想。前几天，我8岁的儿子问了我一个问题：“妈妈，你年轻的时候，长大后想做什么？”“我想当医生和记者，”我回答。“哦，但那不是你现在的工作啊。你又不上新闻。”“嗯，对，宝贝，但我以前上过一次。”
And I love that I help people to feel better in person, but also through my writing. I really hope that this book, and maybe even my own story have been helpful for you. And then what's quite fun is there's emails and reflections that I gave to the authors who contributed stories. So I sent myself a future email. Email to Dr. Marianne Trent on the 31st of August 2022. Well, hello future Marianne.
而且我很高兴，我不仅在现实生活中帮助人们感觉好些，也通过我的写作来做到这一点。我真诚地希望这本书，甚至可能还有我自己的故事，能对你有所帮助。接下来很有意思的是，这里有我发给那些贡献了故事的作者们的电子邮件和反思。所以我给自己发了一封未来的电子邮件。发给玛丽安·特朗特博士，日期为2022年8月31日。你好啊，未来的玛丽安。
Currently you are literally hours away from clicking publish on your second book, Baby. It has been quite the project and one which has been wonderful to be part of. It's also been one which has seen your team grow to include an editorial assistant too. Currently, however, you're wondering whether anyone will buy the new book, whether they'll find it helpful, and hoping that the contributors all like the way it looks when it's done.
目前你距离在第二本书上点击“发布”按钮只有几小时之遥了，宝贝。这真是一个相当大的项目，能参与其中实在是一段美妙的经历。这也是一个见证你的团队不断壮大、迎来了助理编辑的项目。然而，目前你正在琢磨是否会有人买这本新书，他们是否会觉得有用，并且希望所有撰稿人都喜欢它完成后的样子。
So how has the last year been for you Marianne of 2022? Have you been able to achieve the goals you set yourself? Did the other book you've already made a start on get published? Did you manage to make time in your diary for the media stuff you so enjoy? How's the pandemic situation? Currently both of your team have COVID-19 and here's hoping that by the time you receive this email that things are feeling a bit less risky on a daily basis. This level of threat is hard to sustain and we weren't geared up for it as humans.
那么，2022年的玛丽安，你过去这一年过得怎么样？你实现自己设定的目标了吗？你已经开了个头的另一本书出版了吗？你设法在日程表里腾出时间给你那么喜欢的媒体工作了吗？疫情情况怎么样？目前你的团队中两名成员都感染了新冠肺炎，希望当你收到这封电子邮件时，日常生活中那种风险的感觉已经少了一些。这种级别的威胁很难维持，而作为人类的我们根本没有为此做好准备。
Currently your kids are both a week away from going back to school and you're already practicing the dance you will do on that first morning when you get home with empty hands. It's not been an easy 18 months for anyone and you're absolutely doing it well enough. Keep doing what you do, even on the days you feel like no one is watching or can't be bothered. People are watching and like what you do and you have the messages from some of them to prove it. Go forth and do great things or just get really good at sitting on the sofa playing homescapes and gardenscapes. So that brings me to the end of my chapter in the clinical psychologist collective.
目前，你的孩子们距离开学返回学校都只有一周时间了，你已经开始练习在那个清晨当你两手空空回到家时要跳的舞了。对任何人来说，这过去的18个月都不容易，而你绝对已经做得足够好了。继续做你正在做的事，即使在那些你觉得没有人关注或者提不起劲的日子里。有人在关注，也喜欢你所做的事情，而且你收到了他们其中一些人的信息可以证明这一点。去吧，去创造伟大的成就，或者就变得非常擅长坐在沙发上玩《梦幻家园》（Homescapes）和《花园造景》（Gardenscapes）吧。这就把我带到了《临床心理学家合集》中我那一章的结尾。
What did you think? I would love to know your thoughts. Please, if you're watching on YouTube, please do drop me a like and a comment. Let me know whether it resonated with you, what it evoked, what it brought up for you. And if you haven't already read the clinical psychologist collective,
你觉得怎么样？我很想知道你的想法。如果你正在YouTube上观看，请务必给我点赞和评论。让我知道它是否引起了你的共鸣，它唤起了什么，它给你带来了什么感受。如果你还没有读过《临床心理学家合集》
you can go along to Amazon by clicking the link in the description or the show notes and you can grab your own copy. People have said it's really really helpful for them in upping their game in reflective writing. If you have already read the book I would be so grateful if you would consider dropping me a review on Amazon or Goodreads. If you are an aspiring psychologist and would like some more free advice, please do come along to my website www.aspiring-psychologist.co.uk where you can download your free psychology This is the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Dredd. Hello, my name is Veronica Kasova. I live in Edinburgh and I just graduated with a Masters in Psychology of Mental Health. Marian recommended me the Clinical Psychologist Collective when I was networking on LinkedIn and I must say I love it. It
你可以通过点击简介或节目说明中的链接前往亚马逊购买属于你自己的副本。人们说这对提升他们的反思写作水平非常有帮助。如果你已经读过这本书，如果你能在亚马逊或Goodreads上给我留个评价，我会非常感激。如果你是一个有志成为心理学家的人，想要获取更多免费建议，请访问我的网站www.aspiring-psychologist.co.uk，在那里你可以下载免费的心理学资料。这里是《有志心理学家播客》，我是玛丽安·德雷德博士。你好，我叫维罗尼卡·卡索娃。我住在爱丁堡，刚刚获得心理健康心理学硕士学位。玛丽安在我通过领英拓展人脉时向我推荐了《临床心理学家合集》，我必须说我太喜欢它了。它
is one of a kind. It's like a window into the lives of people on the path of becoming a psychologist. The stories are unique, honest and filled with a kind of intangible wisdom only personal storytelling can uncover. A common thread in the stories I valued most was to be compassionate not only with others but with myself too. Also not fixating on becoming a psychologist but enjoying life, growth and the final results will come as a byproduct. Marianne thank you for taking the time to collate all the stories. The book is a true gem and I think every aspiring psychologist should have a copy on their shelf. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是独一无二的。它就像一扇窗户，让我们得以窥见那些走在成为心理学家道路上的人们的生活。这些故事独特、真诚，充满了只有个人故事讲述才能展现出的那种无形的智慧。在我最珍视的故事中，一个共同的主题是不仅要对他人充满同情，也要对自己充满同情。同时，不要过分执着于成为一名心理学家，而是要享受生活、享受成长，最终的结果自然会水到渠成。玛丽安，谢谢你花时间整理所有这些故事。这本书是一颗真正的明珠，我认为每一个有志成为心理学家的人书架上都应该有一本。谢谢你。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。